the way we watch films and shows is  changing MEP s vote on new audio-visual  media rules to better protect children  and regulate advertising greenhouse  gases and fine particles in the air  threaten not only the planet but our  health members vote to further reduce  co2 emissions for new cars by 2030 the  ongoing series of debates on the future  of Europe continues this time it's the  Estonian Prime Minister Yuri rat-ass who  takes the floor private companies and  public authorities hold huge quantities  of non personal data Parliament is to  vote on new rules prohibiting the  storage and processing of such data in a  specific Member State some 5 million  Palestinians rely on aid and jobs from  the UN relief and Works Agency MEP s  debate the consequences of the u.s.  decision to end its funding of the  agency  you